south carolina political writer jack
bass and washington post investigations
editor Marilyn Thompson have written
this biography of senator Strom Thurmond
it's our selection this week on
biography on book TV next the author's
discuss their approach to the
unauthorized book they spoke at the
Freedom Forum in Arlington Virginia good
evening and welcome I'm Charles overbee
chairman and CEO of the Freedom Forum
and we are delighted that you have
joined us tonight for our authors forum
most of you know that the Freedom Forum
is a nonpartisan independent foundation
dedicated to free press free speech and
free spirit and our primary mission is
to try to help the public and the media
understand one another better and when
we moved here about ten years ago our
goal was to try to bring in the best and
the brightest to talk about important
issues relating to the media the First
Amendment and journalism and tonight we
have with us in our audience what I call
who I call the founder of our authors
forums Jack Nelson the longtime
Washington bureau chief for the Los
Angeles Times Jack and his wife Barbara
and I were having lunch and he said you
know you don't have a authors over there
at the Freedom Forum and the people
could come in and you could have a
really unique dialogues and exchanges
with these authors
I thought your gets a terrific idea and
then Jack said well you know I've just
written a book
and Jack was our first author and it was
such a really provocative scintillating
evening that we said yes we're going to
do this this is a great idea and we've
been doing it for about seven years and
we do it here and we do it in our
offices in New York and Nashville in San
Francisco and London and all over the
world and I am continually fascinated
with how people love to be able to talk
to an author and listen to them talk
about what went into writing a book and
what is in the book because half the
people don't really read the book so
we're honored tonight to have two
distinguished authors with us and I have
known them both one by reputation and
one personally for many years we're
joined by Jack bass and marriland
Thompson who are the authors of old
strong an unauthorized biography of
Strom Thurmond now both Jack and Marilyn
grew up in South Carolina the states
that old Strom has represented in the
United States Senate for 44 years
both of these authors were political
reporters based in South Carolina when
they developed an interest in Strom
Thurmond how could you be political
reporters and not have an interest in
Strom Thurmond let me tell you just a
bit about Jack bass Jack covered senator
Thurmond between 1963 and 1973 for the
Charlotte Observer
when Thurmond switched to the Republican
Party Jack is a well-known author he's
co-authored five non-fiction books about
the American South two of them unlikely
heroes and taming the storm or about
federal judges and civil rights unlikely
heroes was a history book club alternate
selection and Jack really hit the
jackpot his biography of Judge Frank M
Johnson won the 1994 Robert F Kennedy
Book Award grand prize and he was
presented that award right here and I
remember it well he wrote this book
while he was journalism professor at the
University of
Sippi and that's how bill Ferris we have
known him as long as we have Maryland
Thompson was a reporter in South
Carolina as I told you in the early
1980s she researched and wrote stories
about senator Thurmond for the Columbia
record and not content to be just a
political reporter she had visions of
that being a book she wrote 20 chapters
of a then unpublished biography of
Thurman and so I know you're delighted
that it now is published Marilyn is an
investigations editor at The Washington
Post she also has worked at the
Philadelphia Daily News and the New York
Daily News and she is the author of the
book the Beast how Wed Tech became the
most corrupt little company in America
it's now my pleasure to welcome to the
Freedom Forum two very distinguished
authors we're glad you're here now I'm
going to open up with a few impertinent
questions and then we will go quickly to
our distinguished audience now you've
written this fascinating book it's rich
in detailed historical and personal
anecdotes and I'm fascinated by I know
you like our audience saw Strom Thurmond
in the news just last week you saw him
as he stood there in this solemn
ceremony as President Pro Tem of the
Senate swearing in giving the oath to
Chief Justice Rehnquist at the
impeachment hearings of Bill Clinton
Marilyn what in the world was going on
in your mind when you watched that well
as I watched it I thought my god what a
wonderful moment for him Thurmond has
always been about setting records and
being in the center of the public
attention and I know this must have been
a very proud moment for him although his
role was was quite minimal he will be in
the history books as the man who did it
it was also interesting and Jack and I
have talked a lot about this in the book
he didn't wear reading glasses which for
a 96 year old man was fairly striking
he bent and read the oath to judge
Rehnquist with no visual aid and I know
that that too was sort of a calculated
move on his part but I'm sure that for
Thurmond it was setting another record
setting another moment in history Jack
when you recover in Strom Thurmond as he
was becoming a Republican did you ever
dream that he would be President Pro Tem
of the Senate or would be administering
an oath to the Chief Justice the United
States well I think what's even more
interesting than that if it weren't for
Strom Thurmond and this is this is one
point the book makes William Rehnquist
never would have become Chief Justice of
the United States and in this sense
Strom Thurmond in 1968 really played the
key role in blocking the confirmation of
Abe Fortas as chief justice also in 1968
Strom Thurmond got a commitment from
Canada Richard Nixon to appoint strict
constructionist to the Supreme Court
Strom Thurmond played the kingmaker role
at the 1968 Republican convention for
Richard Nixon to get the nomination and
then Strom Thurmond took George Wallace
at the peak of his power head-on in the
south and five weeks before that
election
Wallace led in Tennessee North Carolina
South Carolina and Florida Thurmond got
in and went head to head Nixon carried
all for those states by thin margins and
collectively they provided his margin of
victory in Nixon appointed William
Rehnquist to the Supreme Court as well
as three other justices do you credit
Strom Thurmond with Nixon's election
frankly I think I don't think Nixon
could have gotten the nomination without
Strom Thurmond I don't think he could
have won without Strom Thurmond you know
Strom Thurmond has been viewed as a
symbol of many things over his career
but I suppose now he is viewed more for
his longevity than anything else
preceding what what do you think
Maryland contributes to that longevity
especially politically
well he has an incredible sense of the
people who elected him an ability to
serve them and to do the constituent
work that is required to come back again
and again and again and he's smart in
that way he's very smart although people
looking from the outside may question
that he has a keen sense of the
constituents who brought him to office I
think that he does in fact set a record
every day now for being the oldest
senator and the longest-serving senator
and that again must make him very proud
Jack you know I have friends whose
parents are in their 80s high 80s than
in their low 90s
and they're facing nursing homes serious
illness let me ask you just point blank
how with it is senator Thurmond I think
senator Thurmond is with it
he has slowed down he's 96 years old and
he did not grant interviews for the
books we had an unauthorized biography
but - one time I spoke to him on the
phone he simply said you know I'm
getting a lot of requests been abused
and I'm turning them all down and we had
further conversation he is he is I think
he is with it but I say he certainly has
slowed down as I think anyone would but
this is a man who still works out every
morning for 45 minutes swims half a mile
once or twice a week
watches the food he eats he's very proud
of all of that when I'm 96 i'ma leave
whatever I want he recently did say that
he's now drinking a glass of wine every
once in a while just for digestion
paulla killer jacket you have any idea
how he has responded to the book my
understanding is he has read every word
and basically basically likes the book
you know I understand certain passages
that he might be just as happy if they
weren't in there and they're probably
certain passages he might wonder about
how they find out about that but uh I
mean strom comes from Edgefield County
which which is
a unique place and you know with this
great history and tradition of men of
action fighters and lovers and Thurmond
fits both roles and comes out of that
very strong tradition you know the eve
of impeachment when the Senate met in
the old Senate chamber and Senator Dodd
of Connecticut talked about how some of
the Charles Sumner was caned by a
representative from South Carolina it's
one of the things that brought in the
civil is Preston Brooks he's from
Edgefield he's buried in Willowbrook
Cemetery in Edgefield where the largest
plot of all belongs to the Thurmond
family and is that whole tradition there
and in Strom Thurmond fits very much
into that tradition this is a man who is
a 41 year old lieutenant colonel on
d-day volunteers that go in with the
82nd airborne on gliders behind German
lines I mean I watched Saving Private
Ryan and I kept thinking of Strom
Thurmond Marylyn you're an aggressive
investigating editor at The Washington
Post do you think because of senator
Thurmond age the washington press corps
has eased up on him they give him more
deference than he's ever gotten before
in his life
well I think that that was also evident
in watching the the Rehnquist
swearing-in that the the Senate itself
treats him with a great deal of
deference there's no one willing to be
that hard on a 96 year old man who has
served as long as he has I don't know
that the press is necessarily eased up I
don't think he's really doing that much
to attract press scrutiny it was
interesting just this past week when he
turned over the chairmanship of Armed
Services we ran an item about that and
Thurmond in classic style made a little
sexist comment at the end of that
presentation and we did report that but
there is no hard scrutiny of him at this
point well you know of course of his
reputation is having an eye for the
women and you and Jack deal with what I
would call even a few salacious details
relating to the
that could if he were say 7476 rather
than 96 or 66 would he be treated
differently with his attitudes and
actions I certainly think that he would
I think that Thurman came of age and was
politically incorrect before before that
term had any meaning whatsoever and
certainly in his his treatment of women
that was the case jack is there any way
that his reputation would have any
influence on him or others in the
impeachment trial going on well you know
an edge peel demand total Strom is being
a man's man you know and I went by his
office on the eve of the impeachment
trial and was told by his one of his
staff members at senator Thurmond
position is that he's going to be a
juror and he's just not saying anything
and keeping quiet but in this case you
know probably half the members of the
Senate have something that could be said
about him in terms of what does
impeachment trial seem to be all about
which would seem to be about you know
what was the truth about what someone
said about their intimate sex life and
certainly Thurmond has had I said this
is this is an area in which he as part
of his reputation in legend I don't know
that you and Maryland have submitted one
of these chapters in your book to Larry
Flynt for the million dollars yet but
you do you did spend the chapter on FMA
Washington an illegitimate daughter that
Thurmond allegedly fathered in 1925 with
a black woman and you cite a lot of
compelling circumstantial evidence that
Thurmond was the father do both of you
believe he was or are you divided on
that I don't know we're not divided on
that we may be divided on what it means
a little bit but I think the extra
circumstantial evidence is quite quite
strong and one could almost say that
Strom Thurmond is something of a link
between Thomas Jefferson and William
Jefferson Clinton in that test
your brother did that I have a heart
what do you think about that man well
it's funny I I did quite a bit of work
on this particular line of investigation
and devoted a good number of years to
trying to find the alleged black
daughter and interview her for the first
time it wasn't very interesting to me
that when the South Carolina Press wrote
about Thurman's reaction to the book as
as quoted from his some of his closest
confidants he likes the book he agrees
with the book he did not dispute this
particular chapter at least in the
recollections that they've given us I
don't know we don't have DNA DNA is a
whole different chapter in our history
right although didn't spare Thomas
Jefferson apparently I want to go to our
distinguished audience so you have a lot
of knowledge about the south though
those I'm looking at right now and I
know you have some questions of both
Maryland and Jack so let me go to the
audience and I'll intersperse it with my
own questions yes Oh would you wait for
the microphone so our c-span audience
can hear this you could tell me what
flank Thurmond change from the AC flat
to the warm water politician transition
well I think it was a 1970 campaign for
governor in South Carolina when John
West the Democrat won against
congressman Albert Watson who is
Thurman's protege in a sense at the time
and Watson ran what even the Republican
mayor of Greenville South Carolina at
the time called a racist campaign and
lost but it's a little more complex than
that but at that point immediately after
that Thurmond became the first member of
the South Carolina congressional
delegation to hire a black person to a
staff position and the person he chose
with the head of the voter education
project in South Carolina who still
works for him Tom Lawson stand does a
very good job part and has done for
close to 30 years but I do think it's
important to to note that preceding the
Dixiecrat campaign was Thurman's tenure
as governor a period when he was known
as one of the most liberal governor's
ever to have come out of the south and
he attracted great national attention
for that and made some very progressive
reforms and statements but shifted to
the dickster Dixiecrat platform and what
many think is a very politically
opportunistic move but I'm inclined to
think that big secret shift was also
moved in part by that whole edge feel
experienced it was when Harry Truman
first began to move towards civil rights
and I think with Thurmond it was sort of
a South honor being attacked in a
certain way and it was that plus the
politics of the situation in that
Thurmond in 1950 was ran for the US
Senate and had planned to run for the US
Senate the Dixiecrat campaign seemed to
be the great way to win and he lost it
was only race the other loss the lost
the u.s. senator Olin Johnston Jack
Nelson but wasn't storm thermal Orion
strong burly a little bit like towards
loss and that George Wallace used to be
considered a liberal too until he found
out that it would help that he'd got
black votes and so leave again
appointing black people including our
position to the government I mean both
of them basically when they found out
that blacks could vote might be a
political power they change their tune
so neither why but really what you say
somebody who decided that
innovations everything that assessment
Jack I mean I think that Thurman's
career shows an incredible ability to
shift with the with the win to do what
he had to do to keep his his base and
and that's one of the reasons that I
think you see such fluctuation in his
public statements and philosophies but I
think also that senator Thurmond it is
not quite as
is in the same sense of George Wallace I
think is probably more opportunistic I
really do and I think with Thurman is
sort of a more of an internal move that
goes with it and I think Thurman partly
through Tom Moss partly through other
associations really did become
sensitized in a sense and in a sense
also went back to his his earlier
instincts but I think certainly politics
was a big part of it with the Thurman
politics is important everything he does
and and everything he does is seen
through a political prism that is almost
instinctive yes bill first in addition
to being a beautifully written book I'm
struck by the irony and humor that you
weave into it I was really fascinated by
the history of Edgefield County and how
in many ways that predicts producing
politicians and figures not unlike Strom
Thurmond for several centuries
well I think it convinced me in doing
the research on it that the environment
really does shape a person I've done it
earlier vodka Judge Frank Johnson in
Alabama a man who came from Winston
County Alabama where more than twice as
many people served in the Union Army in
the Civil War as in the Confederate Army
and he became a great civil rights judge
and he was so shaped by that County and
Thurmond in the same way was so shaped
by Edgefield this county had two heroes
of the Alamo came from Edgefield County
but the author of the Ordinance of
Secession it made South Carolina's first
state to secede the red shirt campaign
tremendous amount of political violence
pitchfork Ben Tillman when the great
really racist autism Thurman was been
Tillman's campaign manager and all of
that depth and all of that experience
and that was the environment in which he
grew up in and and even getting back
though to the Wallace question you know
one thing Wallace did Wallace said he
was wrong we were wrong he said and
Thurman has never said that Thurman has
never said that I think Thurman
genuinely has overcome his record where
racism was involved in his record but I
don't think he has really overcome his
denial of it also I think that it filled
certainly shaped Thurman but the
influence of family was incredibly
important with this man particularly the
father that Jack was just referring to
known as pussyfoot bill Thurman quite a
political operator in his own right
worked for Ben Tillman had great
political ambitions at one time but as
as Strom Thurmond told us and many other
interviewers his daddy might have been
governor he said he had to shoot a man
and there was an incredible scene on the
edge field town square in which the
father gunned down a political opponent
and cold-blood and his political career
took a significant detour at that point
so Thurmond in many senses was living
out the
curiously the dreams of his father who
taught him the law and coached him in
the ways of backwoods South Carolina
politics assisting with bills cultural
question are you surprised that South
Carolina could send both Strom Thurmond
and Fritz Hollings a Democrat to the
Senate and how would they do that well
you have to understand you know Fritz
Hollings is the oldest longest-serving
junior senator in the history of the
United States Senate and I think both of
them really understand the voters of
South Carolina and I remember v Hollings
once saying that the typical South
Carolina and got up in the morning
recited the Pledge of Allegiance alluded
to flag and spent the rest of the day
fighting and what South in a textile
worker really once explained to me Strom
Thurmond's appealed it when I back when
I was a political reporter and I asked
who he was going to vote for in the 72
Senate race he said strong Thurmond and
I said why he said cause he stands up
for what he believes in even when he's
wrong
and so Thurman and Hollings were both
take strong positions on issues and he
may be diametrically opposed and and
frequently are but voters think both of
them they believe what they saying and
and it carries a lot of weight with them
they speak strongly and affirmative ly
and that's true of Hollings as well as
Thurmond and many other South
Carolinians including some at this
podium Jack you said it's gone
everything agree with most of the
Bullock right what about this part of
the book where the woman is that Mitch
Berger
when eating allegedly made love to the
night fever' Carly the execution I mean
III will ask you though I do not I do
not know I do not know but I don't I
have not heard that he has challenged it
that's one of the great legends of his
career and he in one of my early
interviews with Thurmond he talked at
length about this heroic rescue of this
woman who would you know secluded
herself in the house and shooting up the
police as they came together and and
talked about it effusive ly and used it
as a symbol of his heroism but never
revealed what was obvious to virtually
everyone in the county that he was
involved in an affair with her over many
years that was almost a bizarre kind of
story yeah bizarre drifter the back seat
of the car later execution and he didn't
design those bad no I thought he I
thought it was really you know someone
giving aid and comfort to someone in
distress Jack talks about that as if it
is widely known in South Carolina and
even appreciated as legend but we see
similarly salacious material about
President Clinton and is viewed as a
negative how do you explain that oh I
don't know I don't think this story
about Sulu was widely known I think it
was revealed for the first time in the
book and why haven't I read this on the
Drudge Report you have to ask mr. drug
we're joined by Natalie Dupree who is
the second half of the power authorship
of the marriage of deck bass and madly
Natalie welcome you ask the question
that's always in my mind and and and I
are pushed jacked about it
and Marilyn I think ten mortal agrees
with me and attacked us but but to me it
meant what I have read it implies that
there has been a short amount of real
sexual harassment from the Cardinal
senator Thurmond as we know it now of
course the Senate is protected from
those rules but what I don't understand
is that below that the woman who later
became the first woman to be executed in
the state of South Carolina will work
for conferment
and then they have a close relationship
and here we are at the point where where
the president is being impeached Strom
Thurmond was the President Pro Tem of
the Senate and he introduced the means
more on the judge that that a head of
the attending the impeachment and yet
and yet nobody is saying my goodness how
can a man who has done so many
scandalous thing allegedly do this
what's the answer that endless question
I mean odd Antonin as a question is that
when sulo was working for Strom Thurmond
when he was County of Superintendent of
Education was in the 1920s when Warren
Harding was president making love in the
closets in the White House I mean it was
a different time 70 years ago here I
thought we don't have this knife
high-minded academic discussion I was
just trying to put things in historical
perspective yes
what was the Nancy Thurman's political
aspiration if she aspired lleol early
loss at any point maybe just time to
give up cause he wasn't going to that
that my impression is that it wasn't at
one point Strom Thurmond said he thought
Nancy would make a very good United
States Senator and I think it caught her
by surprise and you know she had she's a
woman but they're separated they're not
divorced and they've raised a very fine
family of children who are now adults
very tragically lost a daughter and
Nancy Thurman is a woman whose former
Miss South Carolina
you know she mean he married her when
she had it where she had been an intern
for him when she was 22 years old and he
was 66 but I think there's still
affection there between the two of them
and she is still a woman who has a
presence you know she steps walks into a
room her presence is sort of felt I mean
I think that is true and you know if she
has any political aspirations at this
point she was certainly young enough
still to exercise well and I think also
she struggled with some enormous
personal problems
the Charleston News and courier was the
first to really report her story of the
struggle with alcoholism and it's just a
tragic intersection of alcohol and that
families live lives in Nancy struggle
and the daughter's death in an accident
with a drunk driver but I don't think
that that Nancy ever exhibited any true
political skill at least beyond just
knowing people and shaking the right
hands and being able to kind of coach
Thurman through some of the events that
he attended
we know that the Senate is the world's
most exclusive club or at least it said
to be what do the other senators think
of senator Thurmond well I think I think
they have a certain respect forming this
is a person who got elected to the
Senate as a write-in candidate in 1954
the only person in history ever elected
to either house of Congress as a
write-in candidate and I think when he
got there and elected as a write-in
candidate people knew that there was
something there and and even when
Thurmond was doing the most ardent foes
of civil rights legislation you know as
I won't quote exactly because I
shouldn't be Public Television but you
know Olin Johnson said he believes that
stuff and and so there was a sense of
even conviction I think there and I
think they found this this is someone
who is a formidable foe and you know
when Thurmond was governor he was one of
the most progressive governors in the
south and when Thurmond switched and
crossed the rubicon in that sense and
became an arch-conservative
and particularly on the race issue you
know progressive forces in the south
really lost something Jackie wrote two
great books about federal judges who had
such a positive impact on improving the
racial situation in the south and Strom
Thurmond is known just for the opposite
was it hard to write that book no it
wasn't hard to write the book of Thurman
is so it's such an interesting character
in here and he eventually came around
you know he supported the Voting Rights
extension in 1982 he supported the
Martin Luther King birthday you know he
extended his constituent service to
black people in South Carolina and
Thurman's constituent service is truly
legendary and anybody from South
Carolina want something they call
senator Thurman's office and there is an
immediate response and it creates
tremendous reservoir of goodwill that
probably made the difference in his
getting reelected again at the age of 93
the questions
gene policinski I come from Indiana
where we've never managed to have
anybody in the Senate past three terms
and it breeds the question I guess in my
mind of just lovely should he still be
in the Senate for the people of South
Carolina does what is there a point
where you would having looked at his
life say that's where he should have
retired or you mentioned as a potential
successor where there were others who
might have been better representatives
if you will of the people's health care
I have to yield to the voters of South
Carolina on that question and they
reelected him there was at least a
flurry of activity last late last year
that the Republican Party was trying to
convince him to step aside while they
could still exercise the right to
appoint a successor that fell very flat
so that the Wall Street Journal had an
editorial suggesting he resigned so that
the lame-duck Republican governor of
South Carolina could appoint a success
and I wrote a letter to that and I said
I'm Strom Thurmond hundredth birthday he
plans to get up in the morning look in
the mirror and see the face of a United
States Senator I think that's true with
no reading glasses was Wallace he have
not changed his attitude his choices on
race could you say those oh I probably
not but I think that's part of Thurman's
adaptability to political reality right
and he is certainly he is certainly a
he's a master he is a truly master
politician and and and that's I think is
the key to his success I mean political
boldness this is a man who ran as a
write-in candidate got elected ran as a
third-party candidate for president took
on George Wallace head-on in 1968 you
know really nominee switched political
parties in 1964 joined the Republican
Party at a time when most of the
southern Democratic senators were about
as conservative as he was it was it was
not an alien group that he was with us
fellow Southern Democrats that's part of
it refuses to keep a political enemy
unusual among politicians maybe if you
opposed undeterminable court you to for
your support to
at least neutralizing and then this
record of constituent service and then
in addition to that you know he always
takes a strong stand on issues he
doesn't duck votes he wins respect with
that in that combination I think is what
has made him the most enduring political
figure in America in the 20th century I
covered senator Thurmond back during the
Nixon White House and no important he
was to the Southern Strategy but the
senator Thurmond wasn't really one of
the strong southern senators at the time
how was it that Richard Nixon came to
rely on Strom Thurmond
how did Strom Thurmond work his way in
to the Nixon administration that way
well King Nixon came to South Carolina
for political fundraiser for the
Republicans in 1966 and praised Strom
Thurmond and said Strom is not a racist
and it really I mean thoroughly Thurman
has a weakness of the character
weaknesses probably vanity and you know
and that meant a lot to senator Thurmond
and Harry dent Thurman's top aide at the
time drove Nixon back to the airport was
asking about the 68 campaign Nixon was
concerned about George Wallace and get
said you know Strom Thurmond will take
him on for you Nixon had difficulty
believing that but once convinced of it
he did it do you think that Nixon ever
viewed Strom Thurmond as a political
liability especially after Haynesworth
in Carswell and tried to backtrack or
did they stay close for a long time well
Harry dent then went to the White House
so Thurmond had his inside track there
on anything that he was really
interested in and if it were issues he
was really interested in he did he did
exert some influence yes Ron this
question is directed to both of you
his contributions it seems to me were a
long time ago he may well be interesting
as a historical figure because he's
probably the father of the southern
Republican Party but in last ten or so
here's a peon managing to be able to
read the other bubbles without in flesh
has you really contributed any
substantive in the way that sakes ought
pepper as an elder member of Congress
was right up to his last years making
substantive contributions and Strom
Thurmond in the last decade and anything
but but survived I would be very
hard-pressed to make the case that he's
done anything significant but perhaps
Jack would feel differently well I feel
differently only to the extent that
Thurman's historic impact isn't going to
be found in the annals of legislation
Thurman's historic impact comes in
changing the political culture of the
region and the nation really in changing
the direction of the Republican Party
the reason he had credibility when he
took on George Wallace in 68 is this is
a man who had run as a third party
candidate on the issue of segregation so
he had credibility against George
Wallace no one else would have had he
brought the most conservative elements
in the south into the Republican Party
first breaking the old democratic solid
South with that 48 campaign and then his
switched for Goldwater in 64 and I think
that has had tremendous impact in
changing the direction and the image of
the Republican Party nationally in the
next century presuming that Strom
Thurmond dies in the next century
what will go on his tombstone what's the
inscription on his wife's first wife's
tomb stanchion those of two lines have
granted about you as the wife of you
know Governor George United States sort
of a presidential candidate goes on and
granted but you know but his first wife
was Jean Crouch Thurmond was just a
woman that seemed to be universally
admired go ahead doctor say but is it is
in fact been positive all history or
negative cells to be like fairly
negative I think it slides in the eye of
the beholder you know and we didn't we
didn't exercise too much judgment we
wanted to write it so that Jack Nelson
did read this and say you know this is
pretty negative to me and someone who's
an arch-conservative might say this is
pretty positive to me you can draw your
own conclusion and I think really his
impact will lie in the eye of the
beholder I mean I don't personally agree
with very much of what he's done in the
last 40 years but that's irrelevant in
what the way I write it and we just want
to lay out the story and make him I
think understandable Jack bass Marilyn
Thompson the book is old strong an
unauthorized biography of Strom Thurmond
a fascinating account of the history not
only of Strom Thurmond but southern
politics and the United States thank you
for being here
[Applause]
Jack bass is a journalism professor at
the University of Mississippi Maryland
Thompson is an investigations editor
with the Washington Post together they
wrote this biography of South Carolina
senator Strom Thurmond ol Strom it's
published by Long Street Press
21:40